haha the Joe Rogan experience and when
automation really kicks into focus and
you know however X many years when
millions and millions of jobs go away
we're gonna be confronted with this new
world and this is what a lot of people
are very concerned with when they talk
about the next couple of decades they're
they're very concerned with automation
and they're very concerned with Auto
artificial intelligence artificial
intelligence and that it's not just
going to take away skilled or unskilled
labor but it's also going to take
skilled labor away there's gonna be no
one answering phones anymore it's all
gonna be computers they're very close to
being able to do that right now
where a computer will have a legitimate
conversation with you and you don't even
know that you're talking to a computer
it's crazy it's crazy are you concerned
with sentient artificial intelligence
and in terms of its military
applications in terms of there's there's
a lot of concern that what we're
experiencing now with is particularly
you wouldn't talk about Yemen with
drones yeah
with these piloted things that what
you're gonna have is autonomous weapons
in the future where you just going to be
able to literally release killer robots
I'm very concerned about artificial
intelligence and how quickly this
technology is evolving with very little
oversight or even understanding at the
highest levels of our government
about both what the opportunities are
that it presents and also the very real
dangers of this technology being
weaponized and how quickly that could
spiral out of control
what could we do to stop artificial
intelligence from spiraling Attica
spiraling out of control in particular
what could we do to stop autonomous
weapons so what a lot of people are
really concerned with did you watch that
show black mirror mm-hmm it's a great
show it's on Netflix but a lot of it is
dystopian stories about the future and
one of them is called heavy metal and
it's about this woman being chased by
these little intelligent robots that are
trying to kill her yeah it's terrifying
because this is something that could be
implemented in the battlefield yeah and
we could have if we don't do it first we
could have a situation where our
soldiers are in some sort of a situation
facing off against robots yeah it sounds
like a science fiction movie but it's
not that far away from reality yeah I
think this is one of those things that
of leaders in the global community have
to recognize that some some kind just
just like with nuclear the nuclear arms
race once you start on this race I mean
there are no winners in a nuclear war
everybody loses in that scenario and I
think there's a similar approach that
needs to be taken to the dangers of
artificial intelligence being weaponized
and coming together as a kind of a
global community to say hey this is
something that indane could potentially
if put in the wrong hands and danger all
of us and find the best approach to deal
with that because my concern is as we
see with so many of these other weapon
systems if it's just one country that's
doing it then you have well my gosh if
everyone else is weaponizing but we're
the only ones who are doing the right
thing then is that creating a situation
where our national security is at risk
or our troops are at risk so I think
it's one of those things that you know
that this world is a small place and we
would have a shared interest with
leaders of other countries in the world
to provide the right kinds of checks and
balances on this technology so that it
doesn't become something that's a danger
to humanity and the real fear would be
that someone would not think that at all
yeah that there would be what
every country figure out what the
country is it's some country but like
[ __ ] you we're gonna do whatever we want
we're look you guys took over this world
because of nuclear power we're gonna
take over this world because of
autonomous weapons and artificial
intelligence yeah and we're gonna design
it to go kill Americans yeah I think
that that's why it's important that we
take that we take a global approach to
this you know and because otherwise I
think you do you end up with that
scenario and where you just you know
this race begins and then there's no way
to stop it and it's too late